Céline Dion en guerre contre sa
belle-fille choquée pas choquée voilà ce
que je vous dis comme vous le savez donc
elle a trois garçons les jumeaux et
dinelson son est né René Charles 22 ans
et malheureusement il ressemble un petit
peu à son père il a pris le mauvaise
chose de son père le physique pardon le
plaisance l'addiction au jeu son père
c'était des poker poker mais au point
même que Céline Dion devait rembourser
des ardoises gigantesques lui c'est la
machine poker mais il y passe un temps
fou et on avait dit effectivement sa
mère espérée qui soit plutôt manager de
sa tournée et il avait dit non après il
avait dit qu'il sortirait un EP un
disque un peu rap ça n'a pas marché
aujourd'hui bref il est avec sa copine
et il passe ses journées dans un hôtel
avec gaz à claquer du pognon pendant que
maman est dépressive bah c'est elle qui
a choisi de vivre à Las Vegas en même
temps c'est elle qui l'a foutu
à Vesoul
il y a pas de casino à Vesoul c'est
fascinant donc elle aurait mis à
mi-conneau ce serait
[Rires]
probablement probablement et un écolo
dans un casino ben il serait gay en
jouant à la machine
c'est simple la vie
alors pardon comme depuis tout à l'heure
j'ai quelqu'un qui fait tu sais il doit
être line comme de bien nature
je sais tout du monde on dirait mais
c'est pas déjà elle est pas chez elle sa
sœur vient de s'exprimer elle est à
Denver dans le Colorado en train de se
faire soigner entouré d'experts c'est
vrai qu'elle est enceinte donc et je
pense très sincèrement qu'elle a
d'autres choses
à annuler tout un tas de concerts et de
tourner etc et puis peut-être que là
effectivement il y a quelque chose son
fils juste très court closer avait fait
deux fois ça une sur lui en l'espace
d'un mois un mois et demi en disant
qu'il était lui aussi est très malade
c'était la Une de Closer mi-décembre à
peu près bon il joue énormément depuis
quelques années simplement c'est
quelqu'un qui a été multimillionnaire
avant même de naître bon c'est comme les
fils Beckham c'est comme tout un tas de
fils de personnalités de célébrités ils
sont tous un peu allumés mais ils sont
plein aux as donc là c'est juste deux
jeunes gens pleins rosace qui dépensent
de l'argent elle elle est la fille d'un
tenancier enfin d'un patron de casino de
22 ans qui passe ses journées à pognon
et qui a dit que ton jeu qui passe ses
journées est-ce qu'on est dans le casino
à l'observer etc c'est un gars qui s'est
émancipé de sa maman il a refusé d'être
son manager il a la fibre musicale parce
qu'il a fait du rap et tout à l'heure tu
as été dur tu as dit fais rien du tout
excuse-moi j'ai écouté enfin le de la
vie unanime de tout un tas de
spécialistes sa musique est vraiment pas
mal du tout il s'appelle big d'ailleurs
il assure
mais ça vend pas du tout mais ça n'a
rien vendu
qui compte hein que les ventes ah ça y
est c'est sur 35 maintenant et la
qualité et la qualité oh là là
non mais très franchement il a refusé
d'être son manager il fait sa propre
musique il s'éclate avec sa nana dans un
casino il est plein aux arbres
c'est très simple il joue dans un hôtel
pardon qui s'appelle le win il y a des
caméras partout sa copine c'est la fille
du propriétaire actuel duwin donc oui
c'est assez facile de voir qu'il est
tout une journée sur une machine
poker c'est pas de maladie
quel que soit les vidéos quelle que soit
les photos
alors attends Laurent et après c'est le
mot poker et c'est le mot jeu qui qui te
fait te tromper mais on y avait quand il
prouve et tu joues au poker c'est pas du
tout ça contrairement à ce que Mathieu
mon père merci
vous allez me reprendre combien de temps
le black jack tu peux le jouer
au poker
que j'ai eu d'un coup oh mais bon
j'étais en train de dire je pense
qu'elle est extrêmement
choqué qu'elle soit très inquiète et
qu'elle essaie de se mettre d'accord à
l'époque René il faut savoir qu'il avait
tellement de dettes au César Palace
qu'elle a du prolonger
ses spectacles là-bas pour nettoyer ses
ardoises ça c'est quand même flippant ce
qu'il a rendu extrêmement malade donc je
pense qu'elle commence légèrement à
flipper qu'il a emménagé depuis Noël
avec sa nouvelle nana mais je suis pas
choqué qu'elle s'immiste dans la vie
qu'elle soit inquiète pardon pour la
question on ne peut pas divorcer de sa
maman je vous rappelle c'est moi que des
petits problèmes de jeu il y avait aussi
des petits problèmes comportementaux
avec les femmes renard j'ai dit Las
Vegas
avec des prostituées c'est pas c'est pas
mal de comportement bah oui c'est ce
qu'il veut bah oui c'est les gars c'est
légal
manque de psychologie quand on a une
maman d'abord son fils il a quand même
22 ans c'est un adulte c'est pas un bébé
donc voilà elle a élevé dans un certain
environnement qui peut effectivement le
pousser à ce genre de comportement et
puis d'autre part je pense que pour une
mère se mettre à dos la belle-fille
c'est jamais un bon plan on voit par
exemple Victoria Beckham quand elle a
commencé à dire à son fils et dis donc
moyen elle s'est retrouvée sur la touche
donc c'est pas
j'en ai un qui a 21 ans il est beau
il est beau mon fils
il a une copine ou un copain ou je sais
pas il est il a une petite copine
que je l'aime beaucoup elle est très
sympa
logique des choses qu'une mère s'occupe
de son fils mais au-delà de ça il faut
aussi comprendre que depuis c'est un
adulte mais voilà mais de voilà
qu'est-ce que j'avais dit oui depuis
qu'elle a perdu René j'ai l'impression
qu'elle en manque de repères et la seule
chose la seule chose qu'elle qu'elle a
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle se concentre
sur sa famille donc elle ne s'occupe que
de son fils et voilà de son avenir je
vais vous dire pour conclure quelque
chose je veux dire quelque chose de très
intelligent je préviens avant pour que
les gens se concentre mais c'est pas
méchant ce que je vais dire mais c'était
la tête et les jambes René c'est le
cerveau quand René lui a dit on va faire
Titanic elle a dit jamais de la vie là
c'est centrale cette chanson là t'étais
dit que je ne veux pas ça a été ton plus
gros succès quand il lui dit on va on va
on va on va Vegas elle a dit jamais de
la vie dire ah dégage je ne veux pas
c'est des gens plus gros succès quand il
a chanté Goldman elle est jamais de la
vie j'irai chanter Goldman le français
et que j'avais pas de plus il essaie
toujours plus gros succès l'album de
toutes les grandes décisions elle avait
18 ans j'ai envie de te dire des trucs
pour non mais toutes les grandes
décisions elle avait dit non et c'est
René qui l'a fait et maintenant qui a pu
René bah c'est une boussole qui indique
le sud elle prend toutes les mauvaises
décisions c'est tout c'est tout
est arrivé quand son fils lui a annoncé
qu'il ne voulait officiellement pas
reprendre le rôle de son père la mort de
ma mère aussi ça a beaucoup joué la mort
sur le sujet tout en fou il y a pas
d'argent gagné non il a gardé la main de
René leur mieux fait de garder le
cerveau
[Applaudissements]